président mesdames messieurs mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse aux
ministres affaires européennes est trop
cher monsieur le drian
je suis un peu embêté parce que une
bonne pédagogie c'est la répétition
monsieur bancaire ne va pas me
contredire mais vous poser encore des
questions sur la turquie et la grèce et
monsieur erdogan cm3 est sans doute un
peu vos compétences d'expliquer la
situation vous l'avez très bien fait
pendant les questions précédentes et je
vous en remercie
alors tout le monde a bien compris les
réponses mais on a quand même on est
dans une situation on se dit mais que va
faire l'union européenne combien ça va
nous coûter encore on a déjà payé 3
milliards et quelques comment on va
arrêter cela maintenant monsieur le
ministre pour arrêter cette situation
peut-être revenir aux fondamentaux
est ce que il ne faut pas se poser la
question de lancer un appel solennel à
la turquie mais aussi à la russie parce
que finalement à l'origine ces
bombardements comme un ied libre c'est a
provoqué cette situation
vous devez bien d'accord là dessus alors
que peut faire l'union européenne si ce
n'est lancé un appel très sérieux à la
turquie et à la russie pour essayer de
se mettre d'accord là dessus parce que
vous avez raison les problèmes
humanitaires sont de plus en plus
nombreux et on n'arrivera pas à trouver
d'autres solutions
alors c'est vrai monsieur morel et
ankara il va revenir vous voir pour vous
expliquer à zagreb
les résultats de ses entretiens avec
monsieur erdogan
je sais pas si ça va aboutir à quelque
chose mais il faut sortir de cette
situation et peut-être que au fond c'est
là il faut trouver une solution avec la
turquie et la russie pour essayer oui je
sais bien c'est pas facile mais ces
votes on vous fait confiance monsieur
milices merci de votre réponse